6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Georgie.
Now, if I told you I'd been for a walk to see Big Ben and Buckingham Palace, you'd know
straight away I was in London.
But what if my walk went past cafes selling mozzarella and ricotta, where I smelled freshly
made canolies and focaccia? Where would I be then?
Focaccia and mozzarella, well, you'd be in Italy, right?
Yes, Italy, or little Italy to be exact. The neighbourhood in some cities where Italian
communities settled and made their home.
These Italian arrivals opened shops and cafes selling food to their own communities.
Soon, dishes like spaghetti and meatballs attracted the attention of local people and gradually
Italian food became famous around the world. In this programme, we'll be taking a walk
through two little Italy's, one in Argentina, the other in New York. And as usual, we'll
be learning some useful new vocabulary as well. But before that, I have a question for you,
Georgie. According to a recent U-Gov poll, which Italian food is most popular with British
diners? Is it A, pizza, b, lasagna, or C, garlic bread?
I think it must be pizza.
OK, Georgie, I'll reveal the answer at the end of the programme.
One country Italians moved to was Argentina. In 1898, Giuseppe Banchero arrived in the
neighbourhood of La Boca, the little Italy of Buenos Aires, where many Italian immigrants
started restaurants. Here, Hugo Banchero, grandson of Giuseppe, tells his story to Veronica
Sminc, reporter for BBC World Service programme The Food Chain.
So, what culinary traditions did they bring with them?
Well, our culinary tradition is Pexeria and we incorporated the Faina from Genoa, which
is a pizza with chickpea flour. In 1898, Giuseppe founded his pizza rear, a restaurant selling pizza.
When a business is founded, it's established. Someone starts it up or sets it up.
But probably the best known little Italy in the world is an area of Manhattan's lower east
side in New York. 90% of Italian immigrants who arrived in the US at the turn of the century
came through this neighbourhood.
De Palos, one of the original shops selling Italian food in little Italy, has been serving
customers for 113 years. Here, Lue de Palo, co-owner and great grandson of the original owner,
Salvino, explains more about his family history to BBC World Service programme The Food Chain.
1925, when my grandmother, Concetta and my grandfather, Luigi, got married.
They opened their own shop. It's the shop we continue today. Being the fourth generation,
working alongside my system, Maria and my brother, Sal, and our children, the fifth generation.
Our business has expanded. Expanded to represent the full food culture of the 20 regions of Italy.
Little Italy is the stepping stone of the Italian immigrant. This is where many of the Italians
first came through Ellis Island and then settled here and then eventually moved into mainstream
America throughout the rest of the country.
Lue de Palo is the fourth generation of his family to run the shop and his children will be the fifth.
Frazes like fourth or fifth generation describe the children of people whose parents immigrated
to a particular country. After arriving in New York, many Italian immigrants moved on to start
successful new lives elsewhere. That's why Lue calls Little Italy a stepping stone,
an experience that helps you achieve something else, like a real stepping stone helps you cross a river.
As a result, Italian newcomers became accepted in mainstream America, mainstream,
meaning the culture and customs viewed as normal by most Americans.
It seems we owe a lot to Lue de Palo, but we still don't know which food is most popular here in the UK.
Isn't it time to reveal the answer to your question, Neil?
Right, I asked you which Italian food is most popular in Britain and you said pizza which
would be my guess too, but is the wrong answer I'm afraid? In fact, the top choice for Italian food
fans here in the UK is garlic bread. Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this
programme on Little Italy starting with pizza ria, a restaurant that sells pizza.
If something is founded, it started or established. The adjective culinary describes
anything connected with cooking. Frazes like fourth or fifth generation describe the
children of people whose parents immigrated to a particular country. A stepping stone is an event
or experience that helps you advance or achieve something new. And finally, the adjective mainstream
describes the customs and culture which are accepted as normal by most people in a society.
Once again, our six minutes are up. Until the next time here at six minute English, it's Ciao! Ciao!